okay welcome to the show everybody I
hope your hope you're doing well I'm
doing well personal I'm doing very well
because I got the the cast off my leg
yesterday it's been it's been on my leg
for after the Achilles surgery had been
on for four weeks a month and it finally
came off and that was great the only
problem is that my calf muscle where the
cast was has been unused for a month
it's also gotten no Sun while the other
calf muscles gotten all the work plus
all the Sun so when the cast came off it
basically looks now like like I have the
legs of two different people I got this
shriveled pale leg and then the leg of a
normal person so it looks like I went in
stole two different people's legs
because I wouldn't steal two legs from
one person that would be kind of rude so
I took a normal guy's leg and then I
also took the leg of an adolescent
shut-in and stapled them together I
basically look like a Ripley's Believe
It or Not exhibit now and the only
reason I tell you that is just very I
give you this graphic description on my
legs only because there are some people
who would try to claim that now that I
don't have my cast anymore I lose all my
victim points and my point is that's not
true because number one I still can't
walk so I'm still a [ __ ] and number
two I have weird legs and so that's
gotta count for something that's that's
social stigma okay do you know how often
I I go to a place and there's a sign
outside saying normal legs only allowed
no weird legs it happens all the time so
it is a social sting so I have I have
really now two sources of victimhood
instead of just the one that I had
before let's be very clear about that
all right
um let me a bunch we're gonna talk about
today that there's we're gonna start
with a movement now there's a movement
to boycott something and I know that
that's pretty surprising it's surprising
that people are boycotting because it
had been probably what almost 14 minutes
since the last boycott I was starting to
Jones I was jonesing for another boycott
I'm sure you were too and so we have
another one we'll talk about it this one
is I mean there are so many dumb
boycotts but this one is even
stands out for its dumbness even amidst
all the other dumb ones and we'll talk
about that in a second but first you
know your confidence is very important
and sometimes one change can make all
the difference like for me if I had two
normal legs that would help me with my
confidence but one area that that really
can help with your confidence is your
hair and hair Club knows this and
they're inviting you to become part of
the hair club family to see how getting
the most out of your hair can change
your life they understand the emotions
you're feeling and they know the
questions you have Hair Club is the
leader in total hair solutions with a
legacy of success for over 40 years and
it can be very emotionally difficult for
people when they start to see that
change and start losing the hair it's a
it's a it's a it's seems like a small
change but it affects your appearance so
much and that's why if you go to hair
club comm slash Walsh today you can get
a free hair analysis and a free take
home hair kit all valued at over 300
dollars but you get it again for free
that's hair club comm slash Walsh
for a free hair analysis and free hair
kit hair club comm slash Walsh
experience your hair and your life at
its best
only with hair Club I'm certain you'll
love the club okay so this this shows
just how absurd the boycott culture is
now there as I said have been a lot of
stupid boycotts this one is definitely
up there on the stupid scale
Bernie Marcus is the retired 90 year old
co-founder of Home Depot and he said it
recently in an interview that he's going
to be donating part of his fortune to
Donald Trump's reelection campaign uh-oh
okay we know we know what happens next
he said this in the same interview where
he also said he's gonna be giving away
up to 90% of his wealth and the vast
majority of it is going not to Donald
Trump but to help veterans with
disabilities to help autistic children
to help to help with medical research to
fund medical research research that's
where almost all of his wealth is going
is is in those areas plus a little slice
of it
is going to political causes that he
believes in now this news of course has
had predictable results a boycott Home
Depot hashtag started with a bunch of
leftist swearing that they'll never shop
there again never mind the fact that
most of these people have never used a
screwdriver before don't even know what
a hammer looks like and now they're
boycotting a hardware store which is a
little bit like if I boycotted a yoga
studio you know it's not likely to have
much financial impact on the target of
my outrage and I think the same is here
the same is the case here not to mention
Marcus is retired he doesn't work for
the company anymore and besides the
other retired co-founder Arthur Blank
who owns the Atlanta Falcons he donates
mostly to democratic causes so at most
it's a wash right one one billionaire
gives to Democrats the other gifts to
Republicans who cares the boycott if it
had any effect which it won't but if it
did it would only hurt the current
employees of the of the company who have
nothing to do with what the 90 year old
billionaire co-founder is doing with his
money that's the only people who can be
hurt by this you're not gonna hurt if
you succeeded in hurting anyone you're
not gonna hurt the billionaire 90 year
old who's giving away all of his money
anyway you're just gonna hurt the
average workers at these places now
which is one of the reasons why I mean
there are a lot of reasons why I have an
issue with the the boycott culture and
one is that it's just so frivolous now
it doesn't it doesn't mean anything it's
just it's it's a temporary temper
tantrum that people put on but it
amounts to nothing it doesn't mean
anything I mean it used to be that every
few years there would be a boycott
movement and now you have one every you
know three times a day and it just
doesn't amount to anything and and
oftentimes of course as I said it's
people who aren't even customers or
patrons of the
the thing that they're boycotting that's
why I think it's funny when you have
like with the Nike thing last week where
Nike got rid of the the American flag
shoe and so this time conservatives were
saying how we're gonna boycott Nike
which if you don't want to buy Nike
products because of that I understand
but you know as I'm reading even the
hashtag for that there are a lot of
conservatives say oh of Nikes trash
anyway I didn't listing all the reasons
they hate Nike well okay well that just
that just means you're the part where
you're saying you're gonna boycott that
doesn't mean anything because you're
saying you never wore a customer to
begin with because you think their
products are trash which fine but again
that just means that the boycott doesn't
amount to anything the other problem is
that so often with these boycotts
they're done in such a way that they're
really only gonna hurt the average
employees who work at these places
they're the main ones who are going to
be affected the rich CEOs and the
wealthy people they're not going to feel
much of a hit now especially with this
if these people these boycotting
leftists had any principles if they
actually had authentic convictions they
would be applauding right now because
they would put the political donation
issue to the side and they would
celebrate the fact that this billionaire
is choosing to give almost all of his
money to the poor and the disabled I
mean if your worldview is defined by
something other than just hating Trump
you would applaud this because if that
that's one of the things if the people
on the left this is something they talk
about all the time income inequality
poverty and those are those are serious
I agree that poverty is a is a something
we should be focused on we should be
trying to help the poor but here you
have someone giving billions of dollars
to the poor and to the disadvantaged but
you're gonna throw all that to the side
because oh he's also given a little bit
to Donald Trump it's just you reveal
yourself to be a hypocrite with no
principles all right I have to talk
about this for a minute the the F Steen
/ Epstein I should say f Steen Epstein
whatever the Epstein thing Jeffrey
Epstein is the billionaire financier
well that's supposedly what he is
although it's it's al it's sort of
unclear how he made all his money well I
guess it's becoming clear now how he
made it but allegedly he's a financier
whatever that's supposed to mean
a rich guy a sex offender alleged
pedophile alleged sex trafficker now
arrested on sex trafficking charges
Epstein allegedly ran a giant sex
trafficking ring where he would shuttle
underage girls children between his
various estates and houses and forced
them to have sex offer them up to be
raped in other words by a bunch of his
rich and powerful friends I do think you
know the way that this is being reported
by the media the phrase is being used
most of the time would be well rich men
having sex with underage girls another
way of putting that probably a more
accurate way of putting it is these are
men raping children Epstein is a
criminal
pervert degenerate scumbag and he if
this was a healthy society he would be
frog-marched to the scaffold and hung in
public that's what should happen but
this case is bigger than Epstein he has
as I said a lot of rich and powerful
friends and one of them is Bill Clinton
Bill Clinton flew all around the world
with Epstein the alleged sex trafficker
but Clinton just
put out a statement saying that he knows
nothing about any of Epstein's crimes
you know disavowing and saying ah well I
had nothing to do with that and the
problem is I'm trying to pull up the
statement from Clinton here I guess it
doesn't really it doesn't really matter
the statement is President Clinton knows
nothing about the terrible crimes
Jeffrey Epstein a pleaded guilty to in
Florida some years ago or to those with
which he has been recently charged in
New York in 2002 2003 President Clinton
took a total of four trips on Jeffrey
Epstein's airplane one to Europe one to
Asia two to Africa which includes stops
in connection with the work of the
Clinton Foundation staff supporters of
the foundation and a Secret Service
detail traveled on every leg of every
trip he had one meeting with Epstein in
his heart law office in 2002 and around
the same time he made one brief visit to
Depp's teens New York apartment with a
staff member in a security detail he's
not spoken to Epstein well over a decade
and he's never been to little st. James
Island Epstein's Ranch in New Mexico or
his residence in Florida okay so this
this statement is saying uh look a you
know Clinton Bill Clinton had very
little do the absolute he just flew to
what four different continents with with
Epstein and he went to his apartment and
he flew all around the world but he
doesn't know anything about this right
it if if you have to put out a statement
saying that you know nothing about the
sex trafficking of your friend who you
traveled around the world with the fact
that you need to put out that statement
is not a good sign the fact that Bill
Clinton was the first person to put out
a statement saying oh I don't know
anything about this that's that's also
not a good good sign
for Clinton and we should remember that
Clinton is also an alleged rapist
himself credibly accused rapists very
credibly accused in my opinion so you
don't need to be a detective to put
putting start putting these pieces
together and I think this is why the
story about Epstein is probably going to
fall out of the headlines
very quickly Epstein almost certainly
has dirt on a lot of powerful people
many of them Democrats Republicans - no
doubt but the media won't be able to
focus this just on Republicans as much
as they might like to and they're
already trying like you're hearing a lot
in the media about the comments that
Donald Trump has made about Jeffrey
Epstein in the past back at 2002 Donald
Trump said that I don't have the exact
quote in front of me
Trump said that Epstein is a good guy
and a good friend and he loves beautiful
women many of them on on the younger
side now that's not good to have that
quote out there it doesn't look good
when this is allegedly apparently a sex
trafficker of underage girls and you're
on record say guys a great guy yeah
loves be loves on loves loves you girls
on the younger side it's not a good
thing but we should also note that
Donald Trump and this is a point in his
favor he apparently kicked Jeff Jeffrey
Epstein out of his moral log Largo Club
down in Florida for assaulting or
harassing a girl at the club down there
so now the media is focusing a lot on
the Trump angle but it's going to be
it's going to become increasingly
difficult to make this just about
Republicans and they know that which is
why my prediction is they're just gonna
stop talking about it all together it's
been thought it's been assumed for a
long time that Epstein must have reams
of blackmail of very powerful and
influential people and that's how he's
avoided serious legal consequence for so
long and it looks like the cops may have
found some of that blackmail in a safe
they found tapes some of them with
labels like there was one tape DVD with
a label that said young name and name
now the names were redacted that were of
course it actually had names down we
don't know what the names were but that
sounds an awful lot like it's a tape of
a young woman
whatever her name is and someone else
who Epstein felt the need to record that
rendezvous and then lock it in a safe
with a label like that who knows but it
sounds like that could be the blackmail
that is now coming out as far as I'm
concerned anybody associated with this
anybody involved with it I hope they're
all taken down I hope they all go to
prison and rot I hope they're all
exposed and destroyed and I don't care
Republican Democrat doesn't make a
difference to me all right there was I
wanted to mention this yesterday there
was reportedly an incident at a
Starbucks in Arizona oh well I guess
last week some police officers say that
they were asked to leave or to move to a
different table because they were
sitting next to a customer who was
uncomfortable being around police
officers this customer felt unsafe
apparently and the unsafe feeling
customer reported those feelings to the
staff at Starbucks and the staff rather
than responding by laughing the
customers face as they should have done
actually went up and asked the cops to
get up and leave
the local police union put out a
statement about the incident describing
what happened and here's their
description of it it says yesterday on
Independence Day six police officers
stopped by the Starbucks at Scottsdale
Road and McKellips for coffee the
officers paid for their drinks and stood
together having a cup of coffee before
their long fourth of July shift they
were approached by a barista who knew
one of the officers by name because he's
a regular at the location the BRE
stirrer said that a customer did not
feel safe because of the police presence
the barista asked the officers to move
by the customers line of sight or to
leave disappointed the officers did in
fact leave the treatment of Public
Safety workers could not be more
disheartening while the barista was
polite making such a request that all
was offensive unfortunately such
treatment has become all too common in
2019 all right now Starbucks has
apologized and pledged to do better and
yadda-yadda so on but that's not enough
to stave off though while speaking a
boycott so there was a boycott of
Starbucks over this
there was a boycott Starbucks campaign
so there's boycott Starbucks boycott
Nike boycott Home Depot it's all in a
week
all these boycotts are happening and
that's not to say that it's not without
cause I mean this is this incident mean
this is this is crazy
the fact that the idea the claim that
police officers will be asked to leave
because one customer felt unsafe with
police office in fact if let's just
think about this for a minute if you're
the cashier at a restaurant and there
are a bunch of police officers in the
place and then another customer walks in
and asks you to kick out the police
officers eye there are a lot of reasons
to ignore that request like it's crazy
and unreasonable and just of course I'm
gonna go but also I would be pretty
concerned about why does this person not
want police officers around certainly as
a as someone working behind a register I
would feel a lot safer with the cops so
it's just a general rule of thumb if you
if you work by the register and there
are cops in there and then some other
person walks in says hey can you get rid
of those cops yeah I mean it was we'll
worry about my transaction in a minute
but if you could just kick those cops
out first and hey by the way you see
those security cameras they make me feel
unsafe too I just I feel you know it's
voyeuristic I feel watched if you just
cut those off I think that'd be creative
and the register when it's it's locked
like that it makes it makes me it feels
like you don't trust me so if you can
just open the register and go wait in
the back for 10 minutes
yeah that's see I'd be worried about
that personally so it's obviously
completely ludicrous
it's these cops were paying customers
they weren't by any accounts in there
threatening anybody they were just
sitting there drinking coffee and that
is an important point because when this
controversy was was happening last week
there were a lot of people in this case
defending
Starbucks or at least saying that we
shouldn't be outraged about it and they
were drawing comparisons to the incident
that happened a couple years ago at a
Starbucks in Philadelphia which you may
remember where there was a huge blow-up
because a couple of black men were asked
to leave the establishment and then when
they were fused to the cops were called
on them now I defended Starbucks in that
case I don't defend them here and there
were plenty of liberals online last week
sangala legit said you're a you're a
hypocrite if you would or you're a
racist I mean why else would you say
you're fine with them kicking out black
men but not officers you must be racist
what other explanation could there be
well I'll tell you the other explanation
because there's a very clear difference
in the case a couple of years ago those
people who happen to be black their race
really is not relevant the fact is these
were these were individuals who were
sitting in a busy Starbucks restaurant
taking up tables and not buying anything
now if you've ever been to a busy
Starbucks you know that table space can
be hard to come by there are plenty of
times when I go to Starbucks and I want
to sit down with my laptop and do some
work and I can't because there are
people sitting at the tables which fine
I mean they got there first but if I
came into a Starbucks and I bought
something and I saw someone taking up a
table who hadn't bought anything and was
just sitting there yeah I'd be annoyed
by that it's like you're not a customer
that's that I earned the right to that
table by buying this coffee you didn't
do that you should leave so that was the
issue and with the Starbucks and Philly
that these these people were sitting at
a table not buying anything and you
don't have a right to take up space at a
table if you don't buy something you
have to be a paying customer very simple
policy so the manager who was thrown
under the bus by by the CEO of Starbucks
and was slandered as a racist the
manager who's simply trying to enforce
company policy and a reasonable company
policy went over to the people and said
hey
you got to buy something you're going to
take the table that's fine I'll what do
you want I'll get you a coffee I'll get
you a bottle of water
she offered to serve them like like she
was a waitress actually bring the stuff
to the table for them she was so
desperate to just get them to buy
anything at all just buy anything and
you are a paying customer you could take
the table they categorically refused to
buy something they refused and that's
when she had no choice but to call the
police which went because at that point
they're trespassing when they when you
come into a restaurant say yeah I'm
gonna take up a table I refuse not gonna
buy anything I don't feel like oh yeah
get out of my face I'm not buying
anything well you deserve to be take it
out in handcuffs maybe you're such a
jerk you could just buy a bottle of
water just it just to follow the policy
and and you know earn your right to a
table that's what happened there in this
case these officers had all bought
coffees they were paying customers
sitting at not only paying customers but
reg - apparently at least one of them a
regular paying customer sitting there
enjoying a coffee and they were asked to
leave
not because of company policy but
because one other customer felt unsafe
totally different scenarios and one is
completely justified the other is
completely unjustified I think that's
pretty obvious all right one one other
thing that we're gonna talk about
briefly before we get to emails there's
apparently now maybe you've heard about
this some kind of internet trend where
people do this never lately key oh you
file put it back put it in
oh you if you're listening on iTunes
which which is probably good so you
didn't have to witness that which to me
just even that is one of the most
nauseating videos especially as a
germaphobe III really I feel nausea to
just look like I feel like I might throw
up that was a video of a woman licking a
carton of ice cream at a store and then
putting it back in the freezer and
walking away you'll be happy to know
that the psycho was found and and she
faces 20 years in prison now she's
clearly not gonna actually be sentenced
anything close to twenty years though in
my opinion she would deserve it if she
did but now you've got this trend with
other people apparently going and
licking ice creams or otherwise
dispensing their saliva into various
food items at grocery stores and then
putting the item back and walking away I
saw one where a guy spit into a jug of
iced tea and then put it back and walked
away
now if I were dictator of the country
when I am dictator I should say I will
have armed guards in every grocery store
in the country and they will shoot you
on sight if it even looks like you might
be thinking of licking an ice cream and
also if you squeeze produce items to
check for ripeness and then put them
back you'll be shot on sight if you
leave your shopping carts obviously
without putting them away in the parking
lot you'll be shot on sight
if you take too long at the
self-checkout you'll be shot on sight if
you take more than ten items to the ten
item or less lame you'll be shot on
sight basically it's gonna be a
bloodbath at grocery stores when I'm
dictator but civility will finally rain
supreme at the end of it there'll be
some there will be some growing pains
under my dictatorship but ultimately you
all those of you who survive which will
be probably not many of you well thank
me for these policies that I will put in
place right now though as for this
licking thing I just can't wrap my head
around not just how psychotic you have
to be to do that in the first place but
how stupid you have to be to do
something illegal on camera and then put
it online like you're you're you're
going to be arrested for that you we
have your face it's a it's you yep you
are providing evidence of your own crime
to the public and this of course is very
common it's what people do now it's one
of the reasons why you know I really do
thank God every day that YouTube and
social media was you know didn't exist
certainly when I was in middle school
and by the time I was in late teens it
was first starting to kind of thing it
wasn't anything like it is now and I I
do I feel bad for kids that are growing
up in a culture where this is just
everywhere permeates everything and you
live your life online because and not to
make excuses right and some of the
people doing this they don't look like
kids at all they look like they're in
their 20s but in terms of just video
taking video of yourself committing
crimes and putting on online so that
something kids do a lot and I think it's
it's just there are kids they go through
kids go through a phase of a very stupid
phase where we're very stupid reckless
phase and now they go through that phase
publicly online and they're all carrying
around
phones with cameras on them so they can
document all of it forever
and I feel bad for them for that though
I don't feel bad for the people who go
to jail for licking food products at the
grocery store because that is well
deserved a well deserved punishment all
right Matt Walsh show at gmail.com Matt
well show at gmail.com is the email
address this is from Daniel says hi Matt
just wanted to give you a little extra
information on a point you brought up on
yesterday's show while it is uncommon
sometimes attorneys are appointed
against their will Eve
not a part of the public defender system
per se for example here in Missouri a
few years back the public defender
system was underfunded to the point that
I believe the Supreme Court here found
that it could not provide a meaningful
defense and compliance with the right to
an attorney for the numbers that it was
faced with since attorneys are licensed
by the Supreme Court at least here in
Missouri we were obligated to be subject
to appointments just by virtue of having
a license to practice law even attorneys
that had no experience in criminal
defense or litigation of any sort were
subject to this requirement it didn't
last long before emergency funding came
through and stopped the practice but it
does happen
I didn't personally get appointed under
this situation but my County did start
doing it briefly I think it was even pro
bono at least unless the funding came
through subsequently your point that the
attorneys a certain class of defendant
has a right to our serving voluntary
voluntarily virtue of working for the
public defender's office is correct
probably 99.9% of the time but there are
definitely exceptions yeah I got a few
emails from lawyers making that
correction that yeah we were talking
yesterday someone emailed yesterday
saying you know if we don't have the
right to a doctor
so if universal health care is wrong we
don't have the right to a doctor then
then how do we have the right to an
attorney and I was talking about one of
the reasons one of the differences is
that the attorneys who you have a right
to our public defenders and they get
into that line of work knowing that
that's going to be their job so it's not
really that they're forced it's it's not
compelled labor it's not slave labor
they go into that and some people
corrected me saying that well sometimes
people who are not public defenders can
be forced which fine but the and that
was that wasn't that the premise of my
cousin Vinnie or he ended up
representing a murderer or something or
no he was accused of but I don't
remember I've already said enough wrong
things on the subject I won't add on to
it but the main point though the main
difference as I as I said yesterday is
that your right to an attorney is yes
it's a right that you have but it's even
more so a responsibility that the state
has
to provide you with an attorney because
the state they're the ones who bring the
case against you they're the ones trying
to put you in jail and so it to avoid
many sorts of abuses in our system they
also have the responsibility to at least
give you the chance to defend yourself
by providing you with an attorney and
that's the difference there okay this is
from ELISA says hi Matt my name is ELISA
the question this question may be random
but I'm curious to hear your opinion
also sorry about the length of my the
lengthy intro to my question I have a
best friend who claims to have severe
anxiety the first time she brought this
up it kind of took me off-guard because
she's a happy and outgoing individual as
we got to be closer friends I noticed
she would bring up her anxiety disorder
very often and the more I got to know
her the less I trusted that she actually
had this disorder I also noticed how
popular the subject of anxiety /
depression became outside of my best
friend so many people also claim to have
this disorder and I couldn't help but
find a common trend and then these are
bullet points majority of them being
women they often come off as a misfit or
underdog they all have different colored
hair or piercings or weird tattoos they
all constantly talk about it on social
media or in regular conversation
lastly they are often left-leaning SJW
type people my best friend fits all of
these commonalities I used to invite her
out to the bar or parties but I stopped
because she would give the excuse of her
anxiety preventing her from going I
never really brought the excuses or
bought the excuses because I feel like
it was very picky and choosey also she
really likes to go out with one of her
other best friends it could just be that
she doesn't want to go out with me which
is fine I just don't care to be lied to
my question is is it wrong to feel like
she doesn't actually have an anxiety
disorder do you also notice these trends
when it comes to anxiety disorders if
you do what is your opinion PS you're my
favorite that's really why I read that
whole email is just to get to the PS no
actually I read it because it is an
interesting question so Alyssa I
understand the type you're describing
here but of course people of all type
have anxiety so it's not just
the type you describe and that's part of
my issue and I kind of agree with my
with some of what you're saying anxiety
is a very human condition it comes with
being a human being
unfortunately nobody likes it but it is
it's it's if you're a human you have
anxiety it's just there's no way around
it there is no person on earth who has
no anxiety so I have a big problem with
turning something so normal so integral
to the human condition into a mental
disorder I have a problem with that
because in order to do that we have to
kind of arbitrarily say well well this
amount of anxiety is okay but if you go
over this imaginary anxiety line then
it's a disorder so you're only supposed
to have X amount of anxiety but if you
have Y amount of anxiety then you have a
disorder well it's it's totally
arbitrary
I mean who decides what the correct
amount of anxiety is and how do you
measure it
and how do you quantify it it just it
just it doesn't make any sense and these
are basic questions that we never seem
to ask about these when it comes to this
subject about mental disorders it's like
who decided that that this is the right
amount of anxiety and and how do you
measure it and in I mean in order for it
to be a disorder I mean think about the
word disorder out of order okay well if
we agree that anxiety per se is a part
of the natural order of things for human
beings in that all humans have anxiety
if we agree with that then we can't say
that simply having anxiety is disorder
what you're doing is you're you are
looking at someone and you are saying
okay
well they have a reason so like this
much of their anxiety is is natural
but then there's this extra part where
there's no natural reason for it and so
that's the disorder part it jet it again
it doesn't make sense it's completely
arbitrary now the point you bring up
about girls that have different color
hair and all the different tattoos and
everything and the all the different
piercings and they claim they have
anxiety well of course plenty of people
say they have anxiety everyone does have
anxiety and there are plenty of people
who say they have anxiety disorders who
don't fit that physical description that
you describe however when you look at
someone say a grown woman who has blue
hair and a thousand piercings and a
thousand tattoos and I say this is
someone with two tattoos myself but
someone who's like really into bodily
body modification to the point of where
it really becomes body mutilation and
all the the weird hair and everything I
think that not in every case but many
times that's gonna be someone who
suffered some kind of abuse some kind of
trauma as a child at some point in their
life and that's you know that's I don't
think that's a big secret but someone
who's really into body mutilation is
someone who's got issues I mean someone
who I think oftentimes if you were to
look at their backstory you're gonna
find that they suffered some real trauma
at some point in their life and this and
what they're doing to their body now is
partly an expression of that
well if you do have trauma or if you did
suffer in some way as a child then
there's a certain natural anxiety that
comes with that
is it really disordered so it's just
that I keep going back to the word
arbitrary but that's what it is it's the
same thing
oftentimes with depression where we say
that someone is all well they have the
depression it's a disease they have a
disease of depression well I think that
very often and too
is another thing that is that is at
least to a point is a part of the
natural human condition everybody is
depressed sometimes everyone everyone
suffers despair not just talking about
sadness or having you know being a
little gloomy I'm talking about despair
I mean everyone at various points has
been in despair but I think when you
talk to someone who's been diagnosed as
clinically depressed and you actually
talked to them and you you you find out
what's going on in their life very often
you're going to discover that there are
things happening in their life things
that did happen to them are happening to
them that would naturally cause them to
feel depressed so it's not this sort
sign aside disease it is a it is an
emotional reaction to things that
they're going through it doesn't mean
that we should abandon them to their
depression and say oh well you should
feel depressed forget about you no not
at all not at all but just it's it's
it's it's not a disease it's just it's
it's a reaction the things that in their
life and if you really want to cure the
depression you have to look at those
sources which are which is it's not just
chemicals that there are actual things
in their life there's there's a reason a
deeper reason and you can get to those
reasons and deal with those so yeah I
think that there's a that there are some
issues with with this whole subject with
the way that we approach mental
disorders now it becomes a lot easier
when somebody is having mental issues
psychological issues that are not a part
of the natural human experience at all
well then clearly in that case there's a
there's a disorder there's some kind of
disease like if someone is hallucinating
for instance okay well hallucination is
not it well we can't say oh well
everyone who loosen eight sometimes no I
mean most people don't hallucinate it's
not a natural human thing if that is
happening to you then there's clearly a
problem there's something
in your brain and you got to go get that
looked at and and probably get some kind
of medical treatment right so that is
there are things that can happen I mean
if you're hearing voices if I mean there
there are plenty of you look at someone
who has dementia well it's said that is
a brain disease there's something
happening to their brain it's not a
natural thing it's a disease that's
completely different from an emotional
experience which is a part of the
natural human state all right I guess we
will I will read one more this is from
Noah says hi Matt my name is Noah I'm 18
years old from Colorado in your last
episode you said that science makes the
creation account in Genesis irrelevant I
don't agree with you on the subject I
have a quick question which is this why
would God purposely lie to us about the
creation when nothing would have been
wrong if he told the truth thanks for
taking the time to read this if you did
well just I want to clarify no I didn't
say the Genesis account is irrelevant I
didn't say that at all I don't believe
that that's not the point that I was
trying to convey maybe I didn't do a
good job of conveying it my point is
just when trying to understand the Bible
trying to interpret it correctly we have
to understand what genre any particular
passage or book belongs to and they
don't all belong to the same genre and I
think everyone agrees with that right
everyone knows that they're not all the
same genre so that's the first point and
then the second point just relates that
okay so we look at Genesis we have to
decide what genre is it if it is a more
sort of metaphorical genre that doesn't
mean that God's lying to us it doesn't
mean that it's irrelevant any more than
revelation which is obviously heavily
metaphorical but not a lie it's not
irrelevant it's certainly not a lie it's
just it's just a it's it's just a
different sort of thing it's not like
the Gospels which are biographical and
which in a pretty straightforward way
just communicate what happened
revelation is not that it's much more
poetic much more metaphorical and then I
would say that Genesis is a similar sort
of thing although it's not apocalyptic
literature like joke revelation is one
of the ways that we know that it is at
least partly metaphorical is that we
understand the science and we know that
the literal interpretation just doesn't
work with what we already know about
reality that's one of the ways that we
know that and as I pointed out I think
it's a very crucial point as I and I've
said this many times but that for a long
time people thought that the Sun orbits
the earth and because they thought that
they would interpret certain biblical
passages as sort of literal descriptions
of celestial phenomena there are there
are certain biblical passages which if
you read literally would seem to say
that the Sun orbits the earth and the
earth is the center of the universe
well once we were able to actually look
and see and say that okay but that's not
the case it simply is not true that's
not how the world that's not reality
then we had to go back and say okay well
we must have misinterpreted those
passages and then we started to take
some of that language and interpret it
in more of a metaphorical way which
isn't to say those passages were lies
it's to say that we misunderstood them
and one of the reasons we misunderstood
them is because we didn't have a because
we had a we were ignorant of some things
about the natural world and once those
once those gaps in our knowledge were
filled in well now we were better able
to go back and say okay well now I think
I understand better what these passages
are actually saying and I think it's
it's a similar thing with with with
Genesis very similar thing all right we
will leave it there
thanks everybody for watching thanks for
listening Godspeed today on the Ben
Shapiro show we check in with the
Jeffrey Epstein case who is implicated
and who is it that's today on the bench
Bureau show